you really need a haircut
yeah
pretty long
you like it or you don't like it i think
it's time to go
i think this is the longest my beard's
ever been
[Music]
a huge mess but i will clean it up
there you go well what do you think huh
looking better i keep the beard or
should we do something different
it was a pretty solid goatee yeah yeah
you like
[Music]
you it that does that look good yeah you
look handsome with it yo you think i
should keep this forever keep it keep it
what do you think babe you like it
nathan do i have an excellent moustache
hmm
so becca do you like it or do you love
it
that your favorite one so far i think so
okay
luke here at the outdoor boys youtube
channel and i'm in alaska i'm going
spear fishing
well 2021 is a weird year and to make it
even weirder i've gotten into spear
fishing i really love doing it but i
don't live by the ocean so whenever i'm
traveling i try to see if i can't get a
chance to go do some spear fishing
that's kind of what i'm doing this year
so when i got unexpectedly stuck in
alaska for a couple weeks i decided to
see if i couldn't go spear fishing and
i'm going to do exactly that i'm going
spearfishing for northern pike
[Music]
all right i think this is where i'm
supposed to meet up with everyone
all right guys we've got a group here
that's meeting up to do some spear
fishing and fresh water for northern
pike so i've never been with these guys
just kind of met up by chance so uh i'm
gonna just see if i can keep up with
everybody and not embarrass myself well
before we head off i got to change into
my wetsuit and uh
i'm not 100 sure how i'm going to pull
that off but i'm not going to film it so
it wasn't easy but i got it done
it's nice when you're wearing stretchy
camo pants in public when you got a
group of people to do it with you you
know
look at that that is sexy
all right we're just carpooling over to
the lake and uh we're gonna go see what
this is like remember kids don't go to a
second location with someone you met
online
[Music]
nothing like sitting in the rain in
alaska taking your shirt off
i was thinking like
it's like full body spanx
you gotta spray yourself down with some
sort of like conditioner or shampoo or
you know baby shampoo otherwise
it sticks against your skin and you tear
your wetsuit so i actually just bought a
brand new three prong but because i
wasn't planning on doing this i didn't
bring it so
i now own two brand new three phones
look at that it doesn't matter
you know i got into spear fishing just
so i could wear a knife on my
leg ready to do this let's do it man i'm
excited we got quite a group of people
here all right guys we're going after
northern pike and i know a lot of people
consider northern pike a valued trophy
fish and they are they're an absolute
wonderful fish to catch but they are
very invasive in this part of alaska
they've been illegally introduced and
they cause a lot of damage to the trout
and salmon and native populations and
the populations just absolutely explode
in these lakes and because there's
nothing that preys on them the
populations explode they wipe out the
native fish then the pike populations
collapse and you have both bad salmon
fishing and bad northern pike fishing
and the fish we catch are going to get
donated to the native hospital in
anchorage people from the bush who end
up flying to the hospital for treatment
often really miss having wild foodie
they live off of wild meats their
traditional diets and so people who have
wild meat will can donate it to the
hospital to help prepare traditional
meals that the people are used to and
it's a nice thing to do for people that
are having a rough time in the hospital
so that's what we're going to be doing
with the meat here but i've never been
to this particular lake but there are a
lot of lakes here in this part of alaska
that are absolutely crawling with
invasive pike
i've been on some lakes where we catch
80 something pike in one day the problem
is is because they have no predators
they end up just multiplying and
multiplying until they start to wipe
each other out and they get all stunted
and you end up catching you know a
hundred fish in one day but they're all
kind of tiny and runty so coming in here
and thinning them out a little bit it's
not only good for the native fish but
also good for the pike fishermen because
it keeps those pike from ending up being
super small if you can thin them out a
little bit i'm going fishing for a fish
i've never speared before in a place
i've never speared before with gear i've
never used before with people i've never
met before this is a day of firsts
four or five inches above the water fat
boat coming in if any time you guys can
rally together
all right guys here we are we're gonna
try this out we're breaking up into
pairs and each of the canoes are kind of
picking a little cove and
we're gonna go along and see if we can't
poke a pike
so this is my first time diving in fresh
water and it was a bit of a murky
experience you can see that the
visibility was only a couple feet here
it's in really shallow water and we
ended up having to go right up into the
shore to be able to see the bottom so i
think i'm only in a foot and a half two
feet of water right here
and uh the camera is mounted on the top
of my goggles so that when my eyes are
under water sometimes the camera is kind
of half in half out of water
but uh we ended up just kind of swimming
along the shore looking for pike so it
took me about 30 minutes or so to see my
first pike i was swimming a little to
the side and behind drew
and he must have scared a pike because
it starts to swim and i barely get a
glimpse of it through the merc and you
can see it just barely on the camera
here and i got try to get my spear up
and i'm turning my head and it's gone
you know just moved a few inches away
and you couldn't see it anymore in the
in the merc
so and that was what it was kind of like
for the first little bit you just you
would see these little shadows coming in
and out as you were scaring pike away
but you just briefly see them and
wouldn't have time to get your spear up
but it was really cool we're in this
margins here and we're going under lily
pads and in weed beds and crawling over
logs and just kind of hoping to find a
pike hidden away under a log or under a
lily pad or something like that
even though the visibility was garbage
we saw a lot of cool stuff i found these
big old fresh water clams and saw a
bunch of uh freshwater lice and shrimp
and one guy got a leech on his face so
that's kind of neat but right here i saw
another pike and i tried to chase him a
little bit to get a better shot at him
and he disappeared into these weeds
well that was an interesting experience
the visibility is only like a foot or
two
and uh but it's it's actually really
comfortable this seven mil
wetsuit
i'm actually quite toasty
but uh we spent about an hour kicking
around and i only saw two pike
uh both of them were moving and not like
stationary so they just kind of see them
just kind of come around me and by the
time i got my spear up yeah it was it
was too late it was way cool saw a lot
of clams and little weird little bugs
and fresh water shrimp and stuff it's
hard like there's two that
just kind of like just too late because
they're
right in front of your face
all right so word on the street is even
the guys that have done this a few times
uh had a rough go of it the visibility's
a bit worse than normal
so that makes me feel a little better
you know
[Laughter]
we'll see if anyone else got any there's
a lot of spears in the water today
okay we're back at where we launched the
boats waiting for everyone else to group
and we just saw a little pike jump so
you know we're doing this
so the guy i was diving with named
andrew loaned me his dive light and it
made a huge difference i could kind of
see the pike reflecting gold in the
light and there was about four pike in
this little cove that i saw and one of
them i actually got to spear
unfortunately
my gopro battery died and i didn't get
it on camera
okay i have no idea how much my head cam
was recording because it died right out
there but we just saw one jump and went
in there and just tried to check it
around saw four really quick using a
dive light and i tagged one that came
off the spear
and then these guys
found him
just hanging out on the surface so
so maybe i got an assist
there you go
that's a really a pretty typical sized
pike around here i imagine right yeah
they got tons of teeth on them they'll
chew your fingers up so bad oh yeah look
at those tiny little chompers oh it's
like a stick your finger
pad in there
you woke him up
alex those are yours oh sweet
look at that
well there we go guys that was some
rough visibility but that was loads of
fun
so in the end i think only three fish
got tagged but uh
you know it was a good time but i need
to clean up my fish and get that gutted
before i run out of light all right guys
i'm back at the house and we're gonna
cook up one of those pike we were gonna
donate them but because we shot so few
of them uh we decided not to waste the
hospital's time and uh we're just gonna
cook them up so i've got one of them and
i'm gonna cook it up and i'm gonna try
some funky recipes because we are
leaving on a plane tonight and i didn't
have time to go out and do a bunch of
shopping and fancy cooking so we're
gonna do kind of uh
what do we have in the cupboard sort of
cooking thing and i got some fun ideas
if you think that freshwater fish
sometimes tastes a little bit muddy add
buttermilk or vinegar to the meat and
let it sit for just anywhere from 40
minutes to a few hours and just let it
marinate in that just a little bit and
it really cuts out that muddy flavor i
don't know if this pike's gonna taste
that way but i've got a little bit of a
mango vinaigrette here and we're gonna
we're gonna season the meat a little bit
before we start prepping the fish just
to do that
yeah would you like to eat some pike
no
up human
[Music]
all right so pike is infamous for having
lots of little bones
and see these these are y bones you see
how they they're shaped like a y
that's that's why they call them y bones
but they're really easy to take out of
the meat
after it's cooked just marinated a
little bit of vinegar fried a little oil
seasoned with a little bit of garlic
salt nothing fancy
pike have really tiny little scales too
so if you fry them in oil if the skin
tastes really good and the scales kind
of just add this nice little crunch like
potato chips
the skin and scale is actually the best
part
you want to see a fancier recipe for
cooking pike i did a catch and cook pike
video
about a year ago i'll put a link down in
the video description of that
well hopefully you guys enjoyed this
short little pike fishing video and uh i
just had a great time it was kind of
this random opportunity to go
spearfishing for pike popped up and i'm
like yeah i gotta do that so
i had a great time but thanks for
watching hope you had a great day and
don't forget to click subscribe put out
new videos every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]